[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue au salon
tech'innove 2019 à paris pour un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 échos votre magazine
consacré à l'actualité économique du
territoire
focus ce mois ci sur l'innovation à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout de suite
le sommaire tech'innove le salon dédié à
l'innovation des rencontres entre
différentes entreprises
parmi elles des sociétés
saint-quentinoise découverte de numerix
une paix est minime antennes et de 6 kg
au une start up innovantes installé au
ski cube le groupe airbus engagés dans
l'innovation de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines notamment dans
le secteur de la cybersécurité entretien
avec frédéric gil directeur d'air du
cyber sécurité france enfin retour sur
l'actualité économique dans le
département notamment sur la prime de
pouvoir d'achat accordée par les chefs
d'entreprise à leurs salariés
[Musique]
tech'innove c'est l'événement pour les
acteurs de l'innovation organisé par la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie
grandes entreprises pme et start-up se
rencontrent à travers quinze mille
rendez vous parmi eux des saint
quentinois saint-quentin-en-yvelines
territoire d'innovation
reportage
[Musique]
je
parmi les grands comptes installé à
saint quentin en yvelines le groupe
airbus des femmes saines space basé à
elancourt avec notamment une activité
innovante autour de la cyber sécurité
nous avons rencontré frédéric gil
directeur cybersécurité france chez
airbus
regardez avec jules bonjour bonjour
alors avec le développement de
l'internet des objets connectés et le
secteur du numérique plus globalement
les attaques informatiques se
multiplient avec comme prévisions une
hausse de 500 % d'ici à 2020 alors
comment airbus cybersécurité se saisit
de ce problème alors on a on a un peu
anticipé cette question parce que cette
progression elle existe depuis déjà
quelques années
chez nous on constate donc on surveille
des clients au quotidien et on constate
des augmentations de fluides attaque
très important donc on s'en saisit
d'abord en étant capable de recruter des
experts en cybersécurité donc chez
airbus cybersécurité au total on est
sept sont experts et on participe à la
génération de nouveaux talents
quelle innovation vous proposer on voit
la cyber range derrière vous alors la
cyber ans c'est un élément d'innovation
donc face à ces enjeux où on a sans
arrêt de nouvelles surfaces attaques
notamment avec des objets connectés
nouveau il est essentiel d'être capable
de faire de la simulation et de
l'entraînement donc la plateforme que
vous voyez des remous derrière moi elle
est justement fait pour ça elle est
capable de simuler des environnements
complet industriel société des attaques
et d'entraîner à la fois des futurs
experts mais aussi de tester des
nouveaux produits et elle est mise à
jour en permanence par nos plus grands
experts qui défend nos clients on a ici
à elancourt ceci d'elancourt plus de 300
experts et ils participent à maintenir à
jour sa plateforme
comment vous innovez justement dans le
secteur de la cybersécurité je suppose
qu'il ya pas uniquement se produit non
alors on innove en fait d'abord en y
nommant on innovait énormément
partenariat il faut beaucoup d'agilité
en cybersécurité donc on a des gens qui
innovent chez nous mais on a aussi tout
un réseau de partenaires
il ya des pme il ya des startups
beaucoup de startups
on travaille aussi avec des formations
académiques des labos tout un réseau
qu'on a mis en place et ce travail là il
est fait à la fois de façon cadré par
exemple on répond en consortium a pour
récupérer des budgets d'innovation
européen
il est fait aussi sur des budgets
propres airbus on le fait en organisant
des prix justement des challengers cette
plateforme pour pour faire naître des
talents on le fait d'une manière
générale en ciblant sur des sujets donc
j'ai un exemple à vous donner on a signé
récemment avec
la ville et la communauté
d'agglomération saint quentin pack lido
qui est un projet d'innovation qui
embarque un peu tous ces gens là c'est à
dire qu'il ya des pme des start up
yann où il ya le cnes il ya l'objet
c'est de sécuriser les objets internet
et les échanges des objets internet et
on va faire une expérimentation avec
saint quentin sur de la smart city donc
on est complètement dans un sujet de
coopération
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'open innovation
c'est ça c'est exactement ça concernant
la place de la cybersécurité dans le
groupe airbus parce que airbus on le
connaît pour le transport aérien on le
connaît pour le spatial la défense
finalement quelle est la place de la
cybersécurité dans ce grand ensemble
européen
alors c'est une place importante on a
mesuré l'importance de la cybersécurité
il ya déjà des années d'abord on en sait
depuis longtemps alors je parle de la
cybersécurité que nous offrons à dire
qu'on protège à la fois nous goûterons
protège aussi la défense nationale on
protège les grandes et grands opérateurs
d'importance vitale
on protège énormément de sociétés
privées également
donc en fait s'il ya eu une vraie
décision d'être fort en cybersécurité la
cybersécurité c'est un enjeu de
souveraineté c'est un enjeu français et
européens on peut pas laisser la
compétence cybersécurité à l'extérieur
donc le groupe airbus il est fait pour
ça il crée d'ingénierie pour les avions
mais credit l'ingénierie en
cybersécurité et après elle a besoin
d'agilité et c'est ce qu'on fait en
travaillant avec des pme et des start up
avec jules merci et justement vous
évoquiez la les relations entre grands
groupes et pme et bien nous avons
rencontré une des pme du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines spécialisés
dans la cybersécurité et qui innove
aussi regarder et cette société c'est
numerix une pme qui emploie près de 100
collaborateurs dans toute la france son
siège social est installé à montigny le
bretonneux elle propose des solutions
innovantes dans le numérique et la
cybersécurité
elle réalise près de 6 millions de
chiffre d'affaires par an et nous sommes
avec son pdg et fondateur monde et rails
a dit bonjour mon genre alors
elles sont les solutions que vous
proposez à vos clients à écouter
aujourd'hui les solutions sont diverses
et variées donc nous avons effectivement
trois axes de solutions qu'on propose à
nos clients premièrement c'est le
conseil en technologies ada on parle un
peu des métiers transversaux
ce sont les chefs de projet c'est lé but
de ciani c'est le product owner ce sont
les assurances à maîtrise d'ouvragé
assistance à maîtrise d'oeuvre et donc
ça c'est le premier volet le deuxième ça
va être essentiellement des expertises à
la fin est donc c'est tout ce qui est
opensource mobilité de microsoft donetsk
et oracle est aussi le deal sans oublier
le développement embarqué et le
troisième axe ça va être comme ça ça
concerne donc la lah les tests et
validations la recette donc ça c'est un
peu le volet conseil en technologies de
la barre de numerix technologie en quoi
vos solutions citées innovantes
alors aujourd'hui donc nous avons
affecté mois donc un deuxième axe
stratégique de développement de notre
société qui est effectivement
l'innovation et la recherche et
développement et là on a déjà déposé un
brevet dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité donc s'est infiltrée fille
à double masque qui a été publié en
avril 2015 est aujourd'hui basée sur ce
projet là on a décroché un certain
nombre de travaux de recherche avec
notamment l'inria qui effectivement donc
aujourd'hui avec le on est en train de
travailler sur un projet concept pour
appliquer notre brevet au niveau des
gateways qui sont comme ça et
effectivement avoir donc la
cybersécurité appliquer à l'internet des
objets alors à quoi sert cette auguste
donc aujourd'hui donc ça c'est un type
de connecteur c'est un type de moteur
qui va récupérer des informations qui
viennent d
des capteurs est effectivement donc
aujourd'hui on est en train de sécuriser
dans ce ghetto est là pour effectivement
accompli c'est justement empêcher aller
les intrusions dans au niveau de la
chaîne de la boutique qui sont
effectivement très vénérable parce qu'il
n'y a pas beaucoup de ressources là
dedans monde a dit merci beaucoup pdg et
fondateur du numérique ce et on passe
maintenant au volet financement face à
la difficulté rencontrée par des
entrepreneurs pour financer leurs
innovations la plateforme de financement
initiative sky a décidé de créer un prêt
spécifique à l'innovation les détails
sur ce dispositif avec le directeur du
ski cube
jean luc berho c'est un prix qui est
ouvert aux jeunes entreprises
qui ont un projet innovant et pour juger
de la du côté innovant de ce projet nous
avons mis en place un dispositif de
sélection spécifique à la fois un comité
qui va examiner la pertinence de
l'innovation par rapport au territoire
mais également avec un potentiel de
commercialisation derrière et puis un
deuxième comité qui va plus me étudier
la faisabilité économique et financière
du projet de cinq mille cinq cent mille
euros et avec des possibilités de
différé de remboursement et qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à une année donc c'est
particulièrement important pour
l'entreprise puisqu'elle aura une année
éventuellement devant lille avant de
commencer à rembourser le prêt que nous
leur ont proposé des entreprises qui
souhaitent en bénéficier viennent
prennent contact avec l'équipe ski pub
c'est ses porteurs de projets seront
pris en charge par des techniciens et
dont vous jugeront effectivement de la
viabilité du projet et la pertinence
économique financière et notamment sur
le côté innovation
c'est une innovation dans le secteur du
bien-être développé au ski cube une
cabine de détente et pour lancer la
phase d'industrialisation la start-up 6
kg au va se lancer dans une levée de
fonds à travers un tour de france pour
présenter son produit et attirer des
investisseurs découverte en détente de
cette solution innovante se détendre
avec une promenade en forêt et écouter
le bruit de la nature tout cela en se
faisant masser sur un fauteuil
voilà un des programmes de cyclos cette
cabine bien être développées au ski cube
c'est une machine apparemment commune
mais en fait qui se sert en fait des
nouvelles techniques de massage et
notamment en fait des airbags
on conçoit des programmes avec des
professionnels de
de la sophrologie des hypno thérapeutes
voilà tout et science on ressent quand
même constitué par les gens dont ce
métier les séances durent entre 20 et 30
minutes
cette start up lancée en 2016 alain cube
alliance de paris saclay s'est installé
en janvier 2010 cette hausse qui kube
hôtel entreprises centres de fitness ou
de thalasso cyclo souhaite mailler le
territoire avec cette cabine via un
système de location on est en train de
créer du bien-être automatisés c'est
j'ai une pression je l'enlève à
l'instant t
c'est à dire quelle que soit l'heure du
jour et de la nuit
j'aurai toujours une cabine à proximité
qui me permettra de me détendre en
créant des événements à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise pour essayer de déstresser
les gens que j'ai pris conscience qu'il
fallait automatiser le système pour
finaliser l'automatisation du système la
start up va se lancer dans une campagne
de levée de fonds à travers un tour de
france
objectif récolter 500 mille euros on
s'est dit bon on va les chercher
l'humain pour pouvoir financer ce projet
et c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi un
modèle qui s'appelle le crowfunding en
royalties
la participation au financement du
projet permet de gagner une part du
chiffre d'affaires pendant cinq ans
trois fois le montant investi en cours
de finalisation le tour de france
devrait commencer début avril
passons tout de suite à l'actualité
économique en bref dans les yvelines le
ski cube et le medef yvelines ont
organisé une réunion de décryptage du
budget de l'état 2010 9 pour les
entreprises du territoire des
explications données par des
spécialistes des finances publiques sur
plusieurs dispositions du texte ou
encore la mise en oeuvre du prélèvement
à la source
le premier jet de la loi de finances
était quand même dans la continuité des
lois de finances antérieur avec un le
gouvernement qui s'était engagé à plus
trop changer les règles et à essayer de
deux d'avoir des lois qui pendant trois
ans de bouge pas trop et par contre est
apparue en loi de finances
ces nombres de mesures liées aux
conflits sociaux de la fin d'année dans
ces mesures annoncées en réponse à la
crise des filets jaunes une prime de
pouvoir d'achat défiscaliser jusqu'à
1000 euros au libre choix de l'employeur
de nombreuses entreprises chinoises ont
attribué ce revenu supplémentaire à
leurs employés notamment chez automation
2000 à coignières et à la clinique de
l'europe à port marly
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de nous
avoir suivis vous pouvez revoir cette
émission en replay sur notre site
internet ou sur notre application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]